I didn't know if I had landed in the
hospital or if I landed in hell or
heaven or wherever I was challenges
there's no denying we all have them
these are the stories of ordinary people
facing extraordinary challenges and
emerging better on the other side
I'm Cheryl hunter as a teenager I was
kidnapped and held captive today my
mission is to let you know that you are
bigger than anything that can ever come
your way
join us for these extraordinary stories
and be reminded that your true nature is
to rise what if you lost all the people
who mattered most to you and it happened
all at once that's exactly what happened
to Mary Mary you have overcome more
challenges than any ten people put
together and yet you've managed to rise
you managed to come together you managed
to overcome in a way that could teach
people so much tell me how you do that
this is my newest trophy
it is project semi-colon that if you've
ever heard of them yes when your story
continues these are for suicide
survivors and of course being an angel
lover I decorated mine with angel wings
so that tells you something about how
far down I went I grew up in a rural
farming community and goes for North
Carolina and at a big family I was
blessed with a gifted mind and a gifted
curiosity gene my I had a wonderful
family my father was my best teacher he
taught me everything I need to know
about everything in this world in fact
there's the funny story I still go out
he used to tell me when I would go to
school in the morning when you leave God
is watching that be sure you give him a
good show and even now even this morning
I went to come up here and I said now
God's watching Mary be sure you're gonna
give him a good show today I had really
bad lung disease and still do and so I
suffered for
severe asthma my whole life not the most
pleasant thing to have when you grow up
on a tobacco farm and yet I overcame
that got a great education went on to
moved to Washington DC after after that
and met my the dream love of my life my
mr. Darcy my Rhett Butler all rolled
into one man he was fabulous a young
actor from New York City and then we I
just had a wonderful life until my own
personal reign of Carib again I guess I
was around 38 to 40 when it began my
grandmother became ill and passed away I
was very close to her so I was very
upset my father my mother my best friend
from college died my roommate that I had
before I moved to DC then my husband was
diagnosed with cancer and for five years
we suffered through that one her end
applies yes to the other one alternative
treatment after the other I remember the
day that I saw the x-rays and I looked
at him and I knew where it was going but
I never told him because I always wanted
to be upbeat and you know have a hope
and but I cried in the bathroom for an
hour and I just couldn't get myself
together and he heard me crying and he
came to the door and he said sweetheart
we're not gonna do it this way we're
just not and when my father died I
wouldn't go out of the house for almost
a year when my husband died I wouldn't
go out of the house for three years I
didn't go to work I didn't go to church
I didn't buy groceries I didn't do
anything
but I went deeper and deeper and deeper
down into depression and I'd like to say
that you know building up a complicated
grief and not recovering from one before
you get into the next builds up these
pain bodies inside you that suddenly
burst one day if you're not careful and
so I slowly but surely started coming
back into life and then my best friend
of 36 years and their customer were
murdered and I lost my mind Cheryl I
laid out in the middle of my kitchen
floor like this and I started praying to
God beam me up please
I cannot take this anymore send me an
you'll send me some kind of sign that
you want me to survive I woke up in a
hospital in Fairfax Virginia in a psych
ward strapped down to it's like that and
I had been there nine days before I woke
up I guess I had a complete break with
reality and the neighbors heard me
screaming and they called the rescue
squad and they brought me to the
hospital and I didn't know if I had
landed in the hospital or if I had
landed in hell or heaven or wherever I
was
the place was stark white and I woke up
and I thought what am I doing here and
then I started to remember the pain and
started crying and crying and then they
would give me more drugs and I would go
out again for another day or two and
then I would come back and finally one
day I said to myself I'm just not going
to keep taking this medication or I'll
never survive this they were piling on
these antipsychotic drugs and stuff and
I was having leg cramps so severe that I
could barely walk I was just I was dying
in there so I said to my psychiatrist
I'm gonna check myself out of here if
you don't stop these drugs he said
you're going to go home from here
and you're going to if you closed your
eyes and look around how many pictures
of people who are alive would be on your
walls or sitting on your piano no one
because everybody in my life is dead and
he said you can't keep living here doing
that looking at that every day and that
was on the one hand on the other hand he
said I'd like for you to read this book
called man's search for meaning by
Viktor Frankl I said how I know alphabet
Frankel I studied him in college and I
met him in 1985 with another one in my
client groups and I don't need to read
that book he said him or me just read it
anyway because you're a story
Meera's dr. Frankel's story I said don't
put me in Frankel in the same sentence I
mean that's an insult to him I mean and
he said well he had to overcome the same
kind of things you're facing today when
he came back into the you know from the
death camps into Vienna and realized
that he had lost his whole family so he
said if you plan a new life and you
promise me you'll do it I'll let you out
before the 21 days mandatory stay in the
hospital I said okay I'm on that
business plan so I got busy I created
business plan I formed my board of
directors in my mind I chose my lawyer I
figured out where he went to live
I said how will I survive the best with
these lungs I'm probably marching toward
a lung transplant at some point and I
figured that I needed to be in a warm
climate I'd like to be by the ocean so I
started doing research so there was
quite some synchronicity when you
finally moved to California tell me
about that married well as I've told
many people before I was standing in a
vat of mud with my heart sinking sinking
sinking I could not find a way to
straight up when I first got out here I
spent days in bed and crying and
carrying on I mean I just couldn't
figure how am I gonna go back to work
how am I going to start a new life I
went down to San Diego when I attended
the conference called the Erickson cut I
believe that was the brief therapy
conference sponsored by the Erickson
foundation there I met a young man who
was from Austria who was running around
doing interviews with famous
psychiatrist from all over the world of
a director and he was building a
documentary about dr. Victor Franco well
when I found that out I'm like no way
and we just became buddies and
throughout the the conference we were
cutting up in acting silly and running
around and doing work after the show was
over I went down to the hotel coffee
shop for dinner and he came in and said
can I have dinner with you and said sure
and people started coming up to our
table and patting him Oh Alex I'm so
honored to meet you Oh Alex please give
you a grandmother my best
Oh Alex when you get back to Vienna tell
your grandmother how much I love your
grandfather's work well even a dumb
person could figure out something's
amiss here he's not some kid with a
camera run me around so I said who are
you really I'm missing something and he
laughed he said I'm nobody they just
want any formation about my grandfather
I said okay I'll bite who should
grandmother and he said Victor Frankl I
said shut up both married to Elvis I
thought it was a joke
no it's true now that's an amazing
coincidence to go from my psychiatrist
walking in seven years before into my
hospital room and saying reread man
search for meaning and meeting his
grandson we made a film about his
grandfather together and love has been
pouring into me from all over the world
because of the Franco connection since
then vat of mud that of love doesn't get
much better than this and just like dr.
Franco I always said regardless of the
circumstances in your life and that's
what in the messages I like to tell
people you can always find meaning
moment to moment hour to hour day to day
or year to year it's always there it's
always cooking in the background you
just have to uncover it doing the work I
do is meaningful and there's no accident
that God put me on this planet to do
this project so I would go out every day
I would discipline myself to go out
every day and spend some time in the
sunshine and I just start suddenly
started realizing that the pain wasn't
gonna be there forever
what would you say there's somebody
who's suffering and feels like well I'm
an administrator for an online
depression group now we have 9,000 200
people on the website and 4500 people on
their Facebook page and there are six of
us who are administrators and we deal
with this every day where I donate 15
hours a week to this group and every day
somebody's going to kill themselves
somebody's been molested somebody's a
victim of child abuse they can't heal
from somebody doesn't have hope and I
tell them the same thing if all you can
do today is put your toe on the floor
that's good enough so realize that it's
those small incremental steps that you
take every single day that gets you to
the next place take that step and yes
it's meaningful next week make the goal
to take a shower because one of the
things we do is let our personal
appearance go when you're in the throes
of depression you can't get out of bed
you can't take a shower you can't get
your hair done you know you can't do
anything understand that the light comes
after the darkness and it's inevitable
because we have everything we need to
succeed inside we just have to let it
happen and focus on giving to others as
much as you can because if you live your
life from the inside out and
from the outside in most of your days
gonna be wonderful
that's been my mantra my whole life and
I'm still doing it so Mary what is next
for you people have been after me for
years to write my life story because
growing up in the 50s and 60s in the
south in a relatively poor state
hard-working you know farm girl to being
in here tonight in Hollywood talking to
you it's really kind of a stretch you
know I want to give people what I call
the real HDL that's going to be the
title of my book I write hope decision
and love the real HDL that's it
and I'll lead from the heart and then
we'll see what else happens thank you
for letting me come today it was such a
joy you lead by example thank you thank
you
Mary shows us that with intention
planning and dedication we can overcome
anything that life throws at us I'll see
you next
[Music]
[Music]
you